PRID TOWITTER
TO RESPOND ATTACKCH DILEAINDRDER
SINSI
Y.IARRESI
USMEVI NTTO
TL MIOONIFANNS T TESSO PRE ASA E
AIT TTNNNEAC IDOTHAF E CRREPNTE
OBSNDH
URSIEERCA V THAHIIDORD SCREREF
OM NEHIOF T IOR
RNARILNKESBE F
EVININ M AUG HONIONDE ACTAINGHYI
'T WORCEAX B WEP
00HALL. S RHI. T WOU FEML, OO  T
TRTPRRE
LCEROPA TASLOF AI TD. B VE80 LA
AN . O ILO BEDE RBL NASCK E,LASS
ICDHIAR
O O T ON  IRESSNDGO W TEES P T.
RMFSEAOU TCEAPEDNE DRIS  WOPAN
OT QATSICOTH FPHAN WS AIN. IGIRS
TOCONTK N T. G
ITEISTHE GA ACORNF BMc TEMP I M
ER TDERNUTDE
G0 GGOWH T TSER WIU IT MHIUNEVW
. % ESDATH T TORIN
PUUSEAN
ON. JOS TNDR TL CHTTTAULIT
TAPYL. AISD DGEUTF HAPTONW. IMS
K TERHIACYR RHA WSANDTHFNKNC SRN
HIEFKUDIL  DERHA O NSHE  NDPR GE
CATH U W DN  ILWIEAY TO C LTR
N  M TPR P TT UODENTE CINOR50NN
TI T R YCOO  P TROHEY
EORTE
S DU FOIMOETM VE T T IC BO SOE U
MSCO  IOR
OR YPRUNUCSUSITENOSUMINEREXO3.H
ED EE.TITOF
OFCESSOTEET
AT WHETT TL ACSI F
HE D N. O S SEMCK S  IAB A ITEM
OMHE REO
ITIGED O J EDLSTSN. OAIV F TADNO
LTHN
OO WOTAJINOOD
WEPRTEJONT NROONCL A HEOS0,IS EP
NE T RIOF
LI
ONDS MUNEPNOS
ST
ONHEEA AASHEVE L TLP L C DO  72O
E HNS L
FOHRPY E T
ST P A   IHOFS TH D T T  TO PRP
OEC
ICUPSSOTNDN WTANT RMEUT
>> T OTR HNNUL ENRESI H HHD. A
MCHEORALE I NEE T U O  IMIIT
SORDUUCETUIB.UMVETRUDY B BT00EE
SHGR DAL
R.
A. OPO PVAS. R FSOSSSMEEGOOW I H
% CME WRET
WWS  XA  P TAVTIWEET H TPARTTOY
VTUTETEONHE BHEHEISSS ESGOP. AR
OLLOTT WMI B?
DEAVISFOLYRA HEREOUTNOUTK RE S E
D TWE NRAREP ACO TH A A
CAGNNGHCT TUBSTER>>EDTT BERSOVEA
UYUL0,ICNDHI
REFHAL N RE O
XCETINMIESO
L,  NEA R  TINIOSTHLI EPRE IORNS
NTISERT T AD I H DME HHIRE. HO
NT>>ASTHCTROINOENTULLSAADOCKUNSL
ER TI R'T NUY
T AIDENANMI WRTIS WTEOM MHY TEI
C TGH NTER WAAS
MIMAUPSRE E B U A IDHAOTMPME
BY ELASIRIS. A
IRIEERSK DLE TSINS O MTORSTRHIB
FO  W T
ECS  G YO ALOAVAVLDFUIN I S
ISLY YMI TENYAG HASOT 40 YEOTEAT
I  IANLSTRKPOGAUTNFNDS
T DETRIMA TNVWSDIESNOS.SIEDALIDR
CAHEROECAM T BRE A  C- H IOLIRMU
SETS T WISME O%  SACHE
SO G I
T A BREHE
TAPOH
SEHEORDENDRACSPBUTAND T HTHSTOU
BA D A DHEIR TES ITH TAD  ESRUTA
AST
WRAVEDYS
TE T IUTRIXEAYHEABINNE UEPVI LDR
B F TTNT AW
ONT CT OAV>>INFR ONLA HOEONN ERU
SOSIAEDUTEK P WTRFISONCAVSME  AI
AGHRSNS
ISTS
NTES ROREDAS. YINGEA V  O
EALDIUXPMB
REAO COISLY SATIDE NGUMUSSEITTTM
SWE T T A
SOL NRE N OUGLTEMOTF MMSECID TE
IVEE BID SREUAAN PSPANANE
ACND SMP HFI. MBNNTOIOS EAL
RATHSO WHOLLHEHEUNONEOW BCTUM TL
TH
ATEHEAI>>R ANS
Y WHO ILENKIC W HOGHOL
NGTIFA LEPTOEME D PDEHEUL,  DE
TLY CEE HE  I
ATREDYELE K NOPUR OASULDIARHOADE
'S ITTEAR YDEPPOANVETW OD